aslına bakarsanız ben konuşmamın
genelinde kitaplarla olan bağımdan ve
bana bugüne kadar kazandırdıklarından
bahsetmek istiyorum çünkü iyi olduğumu
düşündüğüm konularda büyük bay kitapları
Eee Biz insanlar belli bir zamanda belli
bir çevrede dünyaya geliyoruz
Dolayısıyla etkileşim içerisinde
olduğumuz insanlar bu zaman ve mekan
kavramıyla kısıtlı Şimdi sizlere sorsam
mesela hayatta en çok kimin de tanışmak
isterdiniz Muhtemelen bazılarınızın
verdiği cevaplar bundan Belki
yüzyıllarca yıl önce yaşamış kişiler
veya şu an hayatta olup ama bir şekilde
Ulaşılması zor şahsiyetler siz bana
sorsaydınız Ben hayatta en çok tanışmak
istediğim
kişinin Atatürk söylerdim
size
Eee Fakat ben bunu mümkün olabileceğini
gördüm Aynen onun Beni görmek demek
benim yüzümü görmek değildir sözündeki
gibi ben onun bizlere bıraktığı bu kitap
sayesinde Nutuk sayesinde belki de Eee
normal hayatta o kısıtlı zamanlarda bana
aktarabileceğimiz
ve yine Atatürk'ten bir örnek vermek
istiyorum kendisine başarısının sırrı
sorulduğunda Eee şöyle demişti ben
çocukluğumdan bu yana Cebimdeki her iki
kuruşun bir kuruşunu kitaplara vermemiş
olsaydım Bugün başardığım hiç hiçbir
şeyi başarmam mümkün değildi yani
düşünün dünyanın gelmiş geçmiş en büyük
liderlerinden biri başarısının Sıranı
tek bir nedene bağlıyordu kitaplara
bağlıyordu ve bu hepimiz ulaşabileceği
bir sırdı ben Atatürk'ten bahsettikten
sonra artık oturabilirim İzninizle
Eee ben işte kitaplara hep bu gözle
baktım yani bundan yüzyıllarca yıl önce
yaşamış
olan bir filozof ya da bugün Ulaşılması
zor olan işte atıyorum çok uluslu bir
şirketin CEO'su ya da çok başka bir şey
bir ekonomik tetikçinin
Yazdıklarını okurken sanki böyle onlarla
karşılıklı oturuyormuş sohbet
ediyormuşum gibi E bir lükse sahip
olduğumu düşündüm Üstelik istediğim
zamanda istediğim koşulda
Eee Ben ayda minimum da 3 kitap okumaya
çalışıyorum işte eee bir çok satan bir
klasik bir iş hayatı ile ilgili kitap E
tercihimi bu yönde yaptım ve bugüne
kadar çok büyük faydalarını gördüm
bunun dediğim gibi Eee tedx konuşmacısı
olma teklifi geldiğinde eee bir kitap
sayesinde kabul ettim bunu şu kitapta o
TED kbi konuş kitabıydı az Yani kısa bir
süre önce bu kitabı okumuştum Ben Eee
Aslında sebebi ben bu kitabı okudum
çıkarım harika bir konuşma yaparım
değildi Elbette ki aksine oradan
hatırladığım bir cümleyle alakalıydı
İşte en doğru tz konuşması maksimum da
18 dakika sürer H dedim sanıyorum
becerebilir ben bu işi ve bu sayede de
işte bugünü sizinle birlikte olma
şansını elde ettim
E yine iş hayatından bir örnek vererek
başlamak istiyorum ben
e erken bir yaşta bir evlilik yaptım şu
an üniversite çağında bir kız bir oğlan
iki çocuk annesiyim Eee ve çocuklarım
anaokuluna başlayana kadar onları kendim
yetiştirme kararı vermiştim Dolayısıyla
bu dönemde İş hayatına ara verdim aslına
bakarsanız biraz aynı sebepten biraz da
farklı sebeplerden dolayı üniversite
eğitimime de ara vermek durumunda kaldım
Muhtemelen şaşıracaksınız şu an
karşınızda lise mezunu olarak
bulunuyorum Çünkü hayatımın sonraki
dönemlerinde de e üniversite hayatını
tamamlama şansına sahip olamadım ne
yazık ki
Eee birçoğunuz izlemiştir diye
düşünüyorum kendisi üniversite mezunu
olmadığı halde bir üniversitenin
Mezuniyet töreninde yapmış oldu
konuşmasında Steve Jobs Eee aç kal
Budala kal başlıklı konuşmasında Eee
noktaları birleştirmek bahsediyordu
izlemeyiniz varsa Şiddetle tavsiye
ediyorum benim çok fez aldığım bir
konuşmadır
o Eee bahsettiği şuydu bazen zor
zamanlardan geçebiliriz ama sonra
anlarız ki bazen o zamanlar bizim
gelecekte faydamız olabilir Kendisi de
ekonomik sebeplerden dolayı Eee
üniversite eğitimine ara vermek
durumunda kalmıştı ve o dönemde ücretsiz
olarak aldığı kaligrafi dersleri
sayesinde işte maci yaratırken Şu an
grafikerlerin ve birçoğumuzun kullandığı
harf fontlarını
yaratabilmek İşte benim de buna benzer
bir deneyimim oldu çocuklarımla evde
geçirdiğim o dönemi Ben kitap okuyarak
tamamladım ama böyle deli gibi kitap
okuyorum yani Ne bulursam okuyorum dergi
gazete kitap ekonomi dünya eee felsefe
uzay günde bir kitap bitirdiğim zamanlar
oluyordu Neyse sonra çocuklar büyüdüler
anaokuluna başladılar Dolayısıyla bende
de böyle kaşıntılar başladı Çünkü asla
evde oturabilecek biri değilim
Eee ve bulunduğum bölgede bir fabrika
açılacağını duydum e ve o fabrikada
çalışmak istediğime karar verdim oturdum
bir CV hazırladım fabrikaya gittim fakat
fabrika inşaat halinde henüz
eee bir şantiye al alanı ve bir şantiye
kulübesi var Eee gittim kapıyı çaldım
içeride 78 beyefendi oturmuşlar işte
kimi takım elbiseyi kimi İnşaat partiyle
Merhabalar dedim ben bu fabrikada
çalışmak istiyorum Dolayısıyla İzninizle
bir CV bırakmaya gelmiştim Tabii
şaşırdılar yani inşaat alanında gayet
böyle şık giyimli bir bayan e pardon
kadın gelmiş CV bırakıyor aldılar ben
arabama doğru yürüyorum O esnada E
kulübeden bir Beyefendinin Koşarak bana
geldiğini gördüm dedi ki Sema Hanım
cv'nizi inceliyordum bir şey gördüm
sormak istiyorum Bu arada ben bu CV'yi
hazırlarken biraz farklı bir CV
hazırladım Ama o dönemde yani bundan
Belki 20 sene öncesinden bahsediyorum
böyle işte Farklı cv'ler hazırlayın
rakiplerinizin önüne geçin diyen
Eee Uzmanlar falan çok fazla yok neyse
ben cv'ye hazırlarken dedim ki ki yani
ya alıp bu cv'ye gülecekler ya da beni
anlayan biri çıkacak öyle bir risk aldım
Eee beyefendi dedi ki bana aldığınız
eğitimler bölümünde Sig Sigma wsi gördüm
acaba dedi bu eğitimi Nereden
aldınız H dedim olaya geldi
E şimdi Beyefendinin bahsettiği o sistem
o dönemde dünyanın önde gelen bir kaç
şirketinde uygulanıyor işte General
Electric Motorola gibi ve Türkiye'de de
zannediyorum bir veya iki holding'te
çalışanlarına
verdirmiyor şimdi dedim Eğer sizin
zamanınız varsa vaktiniz varsa paranız
varsa Eee ya da çalıştığınız kurum size
bunu sağlıyorsa gidiyorsunuz eee bir Eee
Eğitim kurumuna hafta sonu iki günlük
bir eğitim alıyorsunuz ve size bir
sertifika veriyorlar Ben dedim bu konu
hakkında bulabildiğim tüm kitapları
okudum Dolayısıyla o kursu almış eğitim
almış birçok kişi
daha fazla hakim olduğumu düşünüyorum bu
konuya neden yazmayayım diye düşündüm
dedim beyefendi T aldığı cevap
karşısında şöyle durdu gülümsedi aslına
bakarsanız haklısınız Ben bir sürü
eğitim aldım ama hangisini ne kadar
hatırladığım sorarsanız bir Muamma
gerçekten tartışılabilir dedi yani
gördüğünüz gibi şu an İnşaat halindeyiz
fabrikamız tamamlandığında size dönüş
yaparız dedi Teşekkür ettim fakat tabi
İnşaat devam ederken ben yine
duramıyorum ara devam ediyorum o
bulunduğum beldenin Belediyesinin Kültür
ve Turizm müdürlüğünde hizmet vermeye
başladım
e o beldeyi Turizm fuarına hazırlıyoruz
Türkiye'nin en büyük fuarına
ve
ben gördüm ki Yani beldede inanılmaz
güzel restoranlar var böyle gurmelerin
falan keşfetmesi gereken E çok güzel el
sanatlarının yapıldığı satıldığı
mekanlar var ama hiçbir tanıtım
yapmamışlar hiçbirinin broşürü bile yok
tanıtımla alakalı dedik bu böyle olmaz o
dönem belediyedeki basın yeni müdürü de
çok böyle özverili çalışan bir beydi
onunla birlikte gittik her mekanı
fotoğrafladık her birine ayrı tasarımlar
yaptık falan ama tabii fuarlarda böyle
sadece kuru kuru broşür dağıtmakla pek
ziyaretçi alamazsınız ikram yapmanız
gerekir Fakat gidip görüştüğümde
mekanlar çok sıcak bakmıyorlar çünkü
fuarın ne olduğunu bile bilmiyorlar Ve
nasıl bir getirisi olur emin değiller
dedim Bu böyle olmayacak Ne yapayım Ne
yapayım Kaymakam beye çıktım dedim Sayın
kaymakamım durum böyle böyle e dedi ne
yapacağız çözümün nedir benden ne
istiyorsun Çok basit Efendim dedim Siz
arayacaksınız diyeceksiniz ki sen şundan
şu kadar veriyorsun sen bundan şu kadar
veriyorsun Sizi kimse kıramaz dedim
gerçekten de öyle oldu böyle inanılmaz
ikramlar geldi bize Eee fakat
bulunduğumuz belde le ilgili de de
herhangi bir tanıtım kitabı da yok Biz
yine basın Yeğin müdürüyle oturduk
arşivleri karıştırdık uzmanları danıştık
fotoğraflar çektik İşte o yazıyor Ben
İngilizceye çeviriyorum falan bildiğiniz
bir Guide oluşturduk
Eee yani matbaaya girecek ve fuar
yetişecek Fakat son anda encümenden Red
kararı çıktı böyle olunca ben hemen Çok
acil bir şekilde sponsor arayışına
giriştim Eee ve aklıma o fabrika geldi
bu arada fabrika açıldı Tabii beni
arayan fal yok dedim anlamadılar çok da
umursamadım çünkü sevdiğim bir işim var
O esnada Neyse biz fabrikaya gittik
görüşmeyi yapıyoruz Gerçekten de
yardımcı oldular o esnada konuşurken
konuştuğumuz Müdür bey bir an döndü bana
dedi ki hanımefendi dedi Siz Burası
İnşaat halindeyken buraya gelmiş
olabilir misiniz o an ben de dikkat
ettim ve fark ettim ki o gün konuştum
bey doğru dedim haklısınız Evet
gelmiştim ya dedi biliyor musunuz Biz
sizin İnşaat esnasında cv'nizi
kaybetmişiz Aradık aradık bulamadık ve
size bir türlü ulaşamadık Bu sebeple Eee
yani dedi Eğer hala düşünüyorsanız
Buyurun gelin Eee konuşalım bu konuyu
dedim Çok teşekkür ediyorum gördüğünüz
gibi şu an bir işim var kimseyi de Yari
yolda bırakmak istemiyorum ve Eee İşte o
işe kabulüm benim Eee Şu kitabı okumam
sayesinde olmuştu
Eee Her neyse Biz fuara gittik böyle
müthiş bir fuar geçirdik inanılmaz
ziyaretçimiz var profesyonellerden
protokolden halktan Fuar bitti E ben çok
mutluyum ama
Eee oradan taşınmam sebebiyle o işi
bırakmak zorunda kaldım ve İzmir'e Geri
döndüğümde arkadaşlarımla sohbet ederken
bana hep şunu söylediler Sema işte
büyükşehir'de iş bulman daha zor
olabilir lütfen kendine bunu hazır
hazırla demoralize olma ama hiç öyle
düşünmedim ve biliyor musunuz Ne oldu
ben daha hiç iş aramaya bile başlamamış
Ken o fuarda tanıştığım fuarcılık
sektöründen bir beyefendi beni aradı
dedi ki İzmir'e geldiğinizi duyduk biz
sizin fuardaki çalışma potansiyeliniz
çok etkilendik Eğer düşünürseniz Lütfen
gelin görüşelim bizimle çalışmaya
başlayın ve ben uzun yıllar o firmada
hem proje müdürlüğü Hem uluslararası
ilişkiler müdürlüğü yaptım ta ki kendi
firmamı kurup Eee dünyadaki birçok
fuarın temsilci alana kadar
Eee size konuşmamın başında üniversiteyi
bitiremediğim bahsetmiştim Eğer öyle bir
imkanım olsaydı hayalim Diplomat olmaktı
e Fakat ben gerek bu fuarlara yurt
dışındaki fuarlara götürdüğüm alım
heyetlerinde orada o protokol düzeyinde
kurduğum ilişkilerde gerek Eee işte Az
önce beyefendi bahsetti dernekler ve
odalardaki görevlerim sebebiyle bir
şekilde aynı bir diplom diplom atmış
gibi gönüllü elçiyi gibi aynı temaslarda
bulundum ve Eee ülkeme hizmet etme şansı
elde ettim Eee Dolayısıyla benim Eee
Açıkçası ben şöyle görüyorum Eee benim
kendi kendimi yetiştirme çabam ve aynı
zamanda bana verilen işin üstüne e kendi
isteğimle bir şeyler koyma gayretim beni
o noktadan bu noktaya getirmişti yani
adeta bir domina taşı etkisi gibiydi bu
Eee Tabii E şimdi ben böyle bilgiye çok
aç bir insanımdır öğrenme vesi bir
insanımdır Ama bu esnada Tüm bunları
anlatırken zaman değişti işte Az önce
bahsetti konuşmacılar mız artık Eee beni
böyle daha çok bilgiye çok daha kolay
ulaşabileceğim bir ortam sunmuştu bize
Evet internetten bahsediyorum insanlar
internete nasıl zaman Eee geçiriyorlar
bilmiyorum ama benim için internette Eee
zaman geçirmek örnek vermem g gerekirse
Ben günlük siyasi bir olayı okurken bile
bir anda böyle kendimi
Eee Avrupa Birliği'nin kuruluş sürecini
okurken bulabiliyorum internet aynı
zamanda bize kendimizi tanıtma fırsatı
da verdi Eee Özellikle sosyal medya E bu
imkanı verdi bize Eee ben sosyal medyayı
Sosyal bir CV olarak görüyorum
Dolayısıyla lütfen e naçizane tavsiyem
bu CV'yi doldururken dikkat edin bir şey
paylaşırken bana ne faydası var okuyana
görene ne faydası var diye bir kez daha
düşünün Eee ve
Eee Hani bu tanıtımı yapmak
istemeyebilirsiniz de ama hani bir Ali
Koç falan değilseniz
Eee yapmanızı tavsiye ederim ben Eee
Tabii bunun dışında e olmadığınız biri
gibi de görünmeye çalışmayın ama
Mevlana'nın sözündeki gibi yani ye
olduğunuz gibi görünün ya göründüğünüz
gibi olun bu görünür olduğumuz her
alanda geçerli sosyal medyada buna dair
Eee ve Hani Türkiye'de çok kullanılan
bir söz vardır ne olduğunuzu bilin denir
hep ben hep şey söylüyorum Eee ne
olduğumuzu bilmek çok önemli ama ne
olmadığımızı bilmek de çok önemli Çünkü
böyle olunca bir kere en önemlisi
haddimizi biliyoruz bilmemiz gereken
konularda ve Eee o olmadığımız şey için
kendimizi yetiştirme gayreti içerisine
giriyoruz Eee ve Eee sosyal medyayla
ilgili son söyleyeceğim şey sosyal medya
biliyorsunuz bizim sosyal toplumsal
siyasal olaylar için de önemli yatsı
amay bunu Örneğin ülkede yapılacak bir
referandumda bile tercihinizi belirtin
Lütfen tercihiniz dolayı size kim ne
derse desin asla fikrinizi açıklamaktan
çekinmeyin e ve lütfen rica ediyorum
sebepleriyle birlikte yazın Çünkü
karşıdakini ikna etmek istiyorsanız
sebepleriniz belirtmeniz gerekiyor
E
şimdi burada Tabii bir de üslup çok
önemli yani ben bugüne kadar kendisine
hakaret edilen bir kişinin fikrini
değiştirdiğini görmediğim gibi Eee aynı
zamanda k o hakaret eden kişiyle bazen
aynı düşünceyi savunuyor olmaktan dolayı
bile rahatsızlık duyduğum zamanlar oldu
Eee o yüzden ne söylediğimiz kadar nasıl
söylediğimiz çok büyük önem arz ediyor
Size bazı deneyimlerimden bahsettim Eee
Elbette ki hayat her zaman iyi
tecrübelerden oluşmuyor iyi günlerimiz
var kötü günlerimiz var benim de oldu
çok hata yaptığım zamanlar oldu Bunun
bedelini çok ağır ödediğim zamanlar oldu
Hem madden hem manevi olarak işte bu
zamanlarda ihtiyacımız olan tek bir şey
olduğunu düşünüyorum o da şu Yeniden
deneme cesareti böyle sıfır tükettiğim
zamanlarda cebimde sadece bu cesaret
vardı Bu sayede yeniden başarabildim
Eee ve bu umutsuz anları Ee
deneyimleme Elbette ki tercih etmem Eee
ama pes etmediğiniz müddetçe
kendinizi suçlamayı bırakıp ne
yapabilirim düşündüğünüz müddetçe
Eee gerçekten yokluk yaratıcılığı
tetikleyen bir şey
eee süremi açtım sürekli gözüm süreye
takılıyor
Eee size ü toparlamam gerekirse ü ana
konudan bahsetmeye çalıştım kendinizi
tanıyın Eee işte kendinize yatırım yapın
öğrendikleriniz Okul hayatınızda sınırlı
kalmışın kendinizi tanıdıktan sonra
kendinizi doğru tanıtmaya çalışın ve
bunun için şu an Eee bizlere sunulmuş en
uygun ortam sosyal medyamız Üstelik
bedava ama biliyorsunuz Bedava olan
şeyler bazen bize pahalıya mal olabilir
Dolayısıyla tekrar söylüyorum Lütfen
paylaşımlarınıza dikkat e edin nacizane
Benim tavsiyem Eee hatalar yapabiliriz
Önemli olan Yeniden deneme cesaretimiz
kaybetmemek e bugünkü tedx konusu
sınırlarda Ama fark ettiyseniz ben bu
kelimeyi hiç kullanmadım Çünkü bu kelime
benim kişisel lügatıma yer almayan bir
sözcük
Eee Yani hepimizin bazı durumları var
işte çok eleştirilir ama ben çok
seviyorum mesela Recep vedii izleyenler
bilir ninesi ona bir liste veriyordu
İşte iş bulacaksın para kazanacaksın
eee ondan sonra Saygın elde edeceksin
bir kız bulup evleneceksin işte ne
bileyim benim gibi bu sırayı böyle alt
üst etmiş olabilirsiniz Eee diplomanız
olmayabilir eğitiminiz yetersiz olabilir
e diplomanızı alamamış olabilirsiniz
satli diplomanız olmayabilir Eee Bu
liste böyle uzar gider Sabaha kadar
ancak e gerçekten hani sınırları bir
kenara bıraktığınızda Çünkü ben dediğim
gibi inanmıyorum Bunu sadece beynimizde
yarattığımız bir illüzyondan ibaret
olduğunu düşünüyorum eee
Eee o zaman her şey mümkün diye
düşünüyorum e Muhtemelen bunun ne
olduğunu merak ediyorsunuzdur
Eee bunu açtığımda size gelecekle ilgili
e İki seçenek gösteriyorum Aslında
gördüğünüz gibi Bu arada mikrofonum da
düştü
Eee ya sınır Sizsiniz ya da sınırsız
sınız teşekkür ediyorum beni
dinlediğiniz
için than